all the media has to do you want to shut
up ben shapiro you want to stop scary
dave rubin you know what you do you
start behaving honestly free speech is
more important than ever as the
coronavirus lockdown continues protests
have broken out around the country as
people display their First Amendment
rights city police officials are now
labeling protesting government action
non-essential some have resulted in
arrests this is a great moment to
reflect on where free speech starts
where it ends and it's important to the
citizenry now's the perfect time to
welcome back one of our first guests
ever to the ben shapiro show sunday
special my friend dave rubin dave joined
us a little over a year ago and has
since grown his show the reuben report
to be the most watched show about free
speech on youtube he's not afraid to
have anyone on whether they agree or
disagree
he's a firm believer in everyone having
a chance to have their say his new book
don't burn this book is available
everywhere Tuesday April 28th and it
provides a roadmap for free thinking in
an increasingly censored world in our
discussion we talked about social
media's role in the spread of
information three defining moments that
caused Dave to leave the left what
American government and society will
look like when we come out of the
pandemic and the amazing story of Dave
meeting President Donald Trump at
mar-a-lago
[Music]
welcome to today's it's Sunday special
of course our guest today is Dave Rubin
well we have bonus questions with Dave
as we do every single week if you want
access to the bonus questions you should
go become a member all you have to do is
head on over to daily wire comm slash
subscribe go to the top of our home page
over at daily wire comm you'll see
exactly where to click the to subscribe
once you do you remember and now you can
view all of our bonus questions for Dave
and for all the rest of our stellar
Sunday special guests so I'm excited to
welcome back my good friend Dave Rubin I
believe he's the first repeat guest ever
on the Sunday special so Dave
congratulations I think you were maybe
our first guest ever and I think you're
our first repeat guest so you have made
history here sir Shapiro I'm very
excited because you know I was a little
ahead of the curve on leaving the left
and then I'm a little ahead of the curve
on the home studio and I'm the first
repeat guest on the Ben Shapiro Sunday
special I believe Peterson was your
debut show I was number two but you know
I'll take it so you have a brand new
book out called don't burn this book
people should go buy it then they should
burn it then they should buy a second
copy of don't burn this book so Dave
makes more money and fulfills his people
the the book is is great it's a I mean
I'd blurb dead type I've read a long
time ago the book has a lot of really
terrific advice there's there's a lot to
it we'll get to that in just a second I
first want to talk a little bit about
you know the only thing that's happening
in the news like literally anywhere on
earth like literally there is nothing
else happening there is no sports there
are no movies there's nothing so how
have you been noticing out have you been
living out the coronavirus disaster as
you as you hunker down with your husband
and dog yeah well I guess I was a little
prescient in that I decided to have a
home studio before it was cool I mean in
a lot of ways my life has not changed
because my house is my workplace this is
my garage you know my crew is no longer
coming so my crew is probably operating
how your crew now operates which is in
their own homes so we had to buy a lot
of equipment and we got a satellite on
the roof for Internet and the rest of it
but in terms of my day-to-day life I
mean we're hunkered down here I I did
get a new dog who is about to be put
down because they were closing all the
shelters in LA but you know I'm
basically doing ok and what I'm really
trying to do more than anything else
which I think most of us are trying to
do although we don't really talk about
it is I'm trying to take this time to
kind of better myself
in whatever ways that I can I've been
cooking more I've been doing a little
gardening I'm trying to eat right and
exercise a little bit more and I just
think that whenever we get through this
thing and as we were saying right before
we started it's like we don't know when
this thing is gonna end at this point
and it seems like the experts often know
less than us it's like when we do get
past this I think there's gonna be real
fertile ground for new ideas to flourish
I think people are gonna be thinking
about their jobs in their lives
differently and do you want to commute
do you want to live in a big city how
reliant do you want to be on all of the
institutions that we have what kind of
information do you want to get and where
do you want to get it from I think
there's so many things being flipped
upside down right now and I my goal
really is to just try to remain a voice
of sanity through that we'll see if that
actually comes to fruition but that's
the plan yeah one things that'll be
interesting to see is whether people
sort of revert to their political priors
after this so a major life event and
this is the biggest event that any of us
have ever seen I mean this really does
make 9/11 in terms of scale look almost
most piddling I mean I was there for
9/11 it was a life-changing event and
3,000 Americans died we are you know in
the midst of a global pandemic where
it's not just affecting the United
States affecting everybody the
government is forcibly shutting down the
economy for everybody people are staying
at home and yet you see and it's really
fascinating to watch on Twitter
everybody has reverted back to their
priors like nobody is willing to have a
conversation in almost the same way that
nobody was willing to have a
conversation five minutes ago now the
conversation five minutes ago was a
little bit more woke it was a lot more
about you know identity politics and now
the conversation seems to be about
shaming people for going out to the
grocery store more than anything else or
on the other hand people screaming you
mean about how if you are worried about
coronavirus then it's because you
definitely want to shut down the economy
but it does seem like there's a certain
comfort level that we see people taken
in reverting to all of their prior
biases about the world Ben are you
telling me that you haven't been a good
citizen of Los Angeles and listen to our
Mayor Eric Garcetti who wants us to
snitch on our neighbors if they are
doing something that they're not allowed
to do maybe getting four feet within
another neighbor or something like that
I mean you've got to be a good citizen
here in Los Angeles but yes everybody is
sort of reverting to that but you know
you hit on something interesting there
which is that the woke thing does feel
like it's crumble
right now and look this thing has an
inertia to it that I don't think you
know it's like Freddy Krueger you got to
bury its bones many times over however I
think what a lot of people are realizing
right now is that when we have real
problems
a real worldwide pandemic a real
situation that can cause real death and
and collapse an economy and a million
other cascading things that the gender
or sexuality or skin color of the people
that can solve the problem is pretty
pretty irrelevant so I think that you
know the average person who is maybe on
the on the fence about woke Ness might
actually be seeing through it right now
because when there's real stuff when the
stuffs really hitting the fan none of
that matters and my hope is that the
average person will will take that with
them post coronavirus but you know we'll
see so Dave I want to ask you how you
think politics are going to change
beyond the woke but first I want to
thank our sponsors here at the Ben
Shapiro show I mean this is a really
rough time for everybody people who are
listening people who are watching
certainly for our advertisers you know a
lot of businesses are having a really
tough time right now we are so grateful
to our advertisers that they make it
possible for us to continue to bring
this show to you every single week and
we really appreciate you patronizing our
advertisers and using their products
they appreciate it too thank you so much
and thanks to our advertisers for
keeping this show and shows like it
going we're all trying to get through
this together
and I think that we will let's talk
about the fact that many of us are
working from home if we can work it off
and that means we don't have our IT
departments to protect us we have to
have a VPN we trust now I like to do my
research on my sponsors I recommend
brands my listeners that I personally
believe in I can say with confidence
expressvpn is the best VPN on the market
here is why expressvpn doesn't log your
data there are actual companies that
pledge to protect your data and then
they walk your data and sell it to other
people
they've developed a technology it
expressvpn it's called trusted server it
makes it impossible for their servers to
log any of your information also
expressvpn won't slow down your computer
since I run an Internet company it seems
kind of important that my computer
continued to be fast expressvpn protects
me without slowing down my connections
something else that sets expressvpn
apart from other VPNs it's really easy
to use
unlike other VPNs you don't have to
input or program anything you fire up
the app you click one button to connect
it's so easy that even your grandparents
could use it so
protect yourself with the VPN I use
entrust use my link and expressvpn comm
slash pen today get an extra three
months for free on a one-year package
that's expressive VPN comm slash pen
expressvpn comm slash pendulum or again
that's expressed VPN comm slash bond
okay so let's talk about how politics
are going to change may be permanently
maybe not where do you think politics
are going from there so you've been
you've had a pretty good track record
here of giving a name to each year like
last year was the year of the Dragon and
also of of odd alliances that this year
what what was your call for this year at
the beginning of this year so two years
ago I called it the year of unusual
alliances and that's really when the
whole IDW thing intellectual dark web
sprung out of out of sort of nowhere
although for people like us it wasn't
nowhere because it was bubbling on the
internet from quite some time but the
example I always use of why I called it
unusual alliances was you in sam harris
i mean two guys who disagree on
literally everything from the nature of
reality god and religion and belief to
taxes and states rights and I mean you
guys disagree on any on everything but
you basically became allies through the
free speech thing and through open
inquiry and and being able to debate
ideas and then this year I said this
will be the year that woke ISM collapses
now I didn't anticipate that it was
going to be through coronavirus as we
just talked about but what I did what I
did see and I still see happening and I
think you can even see it right now is
that woke 'no survived the democratic
process the democratic nomination
because it is a constant competition to
destroy it's not a competition to build
so ultimately and and this is what's
happening with bernie right now is he's
limping now towards the convention if it
even makes it that far is that at the
end he is going to be viewed by
tomorrow's progressives as just an old
failed white man and you can see them
you can see aoc kind of turning on him
right now and at the end of the day
because he decided not to burn the whole
thing down when he lost a Hillary last
time and it doesn't look like he's going
to burn the whole thing down when they
hand this thing to buy it and who every
nose is completely incapable of leading
this country I mean Biden should be
retired right now that's just the sad
truth they will have to take Bernie out
because he's an old white man and then
the endless the endless competition to
out woke each other also will burn out
so when Biden now says that no matter
what his his VP is gonna be a woman and
then at the same time Biden will also
tell you as he said at the LGBT equality
forum he said that it's not your
birthday which will be the deciding
factor on what prison you go to it's
whatever gender you identify as so it's
like none of this makes any sense and I
don't think it can survive in a year of
a democratic election that being said
because the Democrats right now are just
such a freaking mess because there is no
there is no unifying principle on the
left anymore the right which I would say
now I'm loosely a part of the right
let's say there is a unifying principle
the principle that you and say Donald
Trump and Ted Cruz and nikki Haley and
all these people have is basically you
believe in the Constitution and you
believe in individual rights now you may
not always act on it appropriately or
exactly perfectly or something like that
but that is the basis for your arguments
right the left has a sort of well
government should do everything and you
know let's just fight about how much it
should do that's not really a unifying
principle that's just sort of I feel a
certain way about something and someone
else feels another certain way the
easiest example of this of course would
be you know Bernie says he's for $15
minimum wage and then to Rashidah Talib
says she's for $20 minimum wage and it's
like well yeah you have no reason to say
you're for 15 that doesn't make sense in
an age of automation and iPads anyway so
why not 20 why not 25 and if you don't
agree with me you're probably a racist
or a bigot or something because you
don't like poor people and blah blah
blah so they don't have a unifying
principle anymore and I think because of
that identity politics woke miss it's
all gonna start eating itself
and then you know just surrounded all of
that you put that all in the bubble of
now what's going on with coronavirus and
people realizing that borders are
important that states rights are
important that guns so you can protect
your family are important
series of other things I think there's a
huge opportunity for for conservatives
libertarians whatever you want to call
that group at the moment
well it'll be really interesting to see
whether there is an actual political
realignment because even inside the
conservative movement I've talked about
this pretty extensively there's been
this gap that's opened up between so the
classical liberal wing libertarian ish
wing of the conservative movement which
is where I consider myself like I'm very
much a conservative on social policies
but not via government via social fabric
now there's a group of people who have
started calling themselves sort of
common good conservatives people who
believe that it's the job of the
government to actually facilitate the
social institutions that I may like but
don't think government actually is able
to facilitate they believe the
government should be used to facilitate
those social institutions and they use
language that sounds very much like some
of the language of left it's just that
their priorities are different and so
the government is supposed to back this
institution as opposed to this
institution and so they're just arguing
over which institution government is
supposed to back not what is the
generalized role of government in
people's lives and and so there's this
this gap that's been open that I think I
wonder if that's the next gap that's
going to open and it's gonna lead to a
pretty significant political realignment
where you see folks like Tucker Carlson
who's you know brilliant and and
Tucker's a terrific entertainer and good
thinker where you see Tucker you know
kind of coming around to the Elizabeth
Warren wing on the one hand and then you
see maybe some dispossessed Democrats on
the other hand going I'm not really
interested in having the government
control every aspect of my life and
moving over into the sort of libertarian
camp and I could see that opening up
that gap in the aftermath of this
particularly because the MOR been
considering it David the more I've been
thinking that what we could be entering
is an era where you have one group of
people who say Roaring Twenties almost
reaction to this which is okay they
locked us in our houses for months on
end they told us I can't do anything I
want to do and when this is over I'm
gonna do whatever I want to do and I
don't want the government in my business
I don't want the government dealing with
me economically I don't want the
government telling me what I can and
cannot do with my life and just leave me
the hell alone there's the the final you
know that the Rand Paul and libertarian
moment finally arrived and on the other
hand you could see people saying listen
this was a a pitch perfect example of
why massive government is necessary sure
there were failures of massive
government in all of this but we need
bigger and stronger government and
everybody's life particularly if we ends
up with a significant recession out of
this which
seems to be a high probability with 30
million people unemployed then a 10
percent 13 percent unemployment rate
could see people come out of this saying
not I need less government in my life
but I need tests probably more
government my life because I have no
other choices that could be the next
battle and that's a battle more about
kind of fundamental principles even then
Wolke ism is so I love that you're
asking about this and and I sort of
loosely write about this idea in the
book because I'm sort of new to this
wing right so I mean I'm in that
classical liberal libertarian part where
you are and you and I have discussed
where you are more conservative socially
and and I can I can get on board that
because you're not trying to legislate
my life so let's put that aside for a
second I actually think that my hope
would be that the roaring 20s of get the
government out of my life I know how I
want to live
let's bring as much back to the states
right now now look I understand and our
founders understood by the way that the
states can't absolutely do everything
right the states can't border can't
control the borders of a national
country they can control their own
borders there are certain things that we
need the federal government to do but my
hope is that most people are gonna
realize boy you know we had this
coronavirus thing and what did I do the
entire time I complained about Trump I
complained about the the doctors I
complained about the supply chain I
complained about our relationship to
China all of these things and maybe just
maybe the answer isn't that we have to
give more power to all of these things
the answer is that we have to take the
power back but also on your point about
this split between common good
conservatism and maybe the classical
liberal libertarian side you know there
was an interesting debate a few months
ago that was happening in the
Twittersphere about what how
conservatives should view porn right now
my personal view is as long as you're
not doing something illegal so it can't
be child porn or something like that
that people ultimately have the choices
that they want in their life and you can
view it you can be part of it whatever
that's that's my view of it I do
understand the more conservative side of
it which says well you know most of the
women that get involved in this are drug
addicted and then they end up in abusive
relationships and there's all sorts of
criminal activity and mafia and all of
that stuff and that their view is that
the common good conservatism has
to stop that because that over the
course of time will erode the family and
then you've eroded society I actually
understand that argument quite well and
I and I'm sympathetic to it I'm actually
not even saying it's wrong I personally
put more of a primacy a more of an
importance on individual freedom and
allowing people to make mistakes along
the way and then hopefully over time
they real those mistakes in I think
that's what the human experiences so I
don't I don't want to use the government
for those sort of moral moves but that's
a great place to for conservatives the
more you know the the common good
conservatives and the classical liberal
libertarians to keep arguing that out
and have that push and pull without
trying to destroy each other and again
we're where that is on the other side
where they debate things without trying
to destroy each other I don't know where
that is well in a second I want to ask
you about you know whether people are
experiencing coronaviruses a wake-up
call because in your new book don't burn
this book you talk about your own
wake-up calls and how you ended up kind
of leaving the left and ending up where
you are politically look into that in
just one second first now is a pretty
great time to think about life insurance
there are lots of things that we look
back on and we think how did I get it so
wrong with that one time I'll add my
business partner Jeremy boring to hire a
person named Michael Moses that guy's a
Yale grad is like oh okay sounds it
sounds great yeah that was a bad mistake
but there are certain things in life you
can't afford to make mistakes about one
of those is life insurance policy genius
well make life insurance happen for you
for the right price the best policy
policy genius makes finding the right
life insurance a breeze in minutes you
can compare quotes from the top insurers
and find your best price you could save
fifteen hundred bucks or more every year
by using policy genius to compare life
insurance policies once you apply the
policy genius team handles all the
paperwork and the red tape for free and
policy genius doesn't just make life
insurance easy they can also help you
find the right home in auto insurance or
disability insurance even if you look
back on those days when you made the
wrong hire and distress you won't have
to be distressed if you use policy
genius calm to get all the insurance
that you need cross that thing off your
to-do list we all get things wrong from
time to time get your life insurance
right at policy genius.com examine the
options before you buy policy genius.com
again that's policy genius calm to be a
responsible human being so David I want
to talk about the the wake-up calls that
you talk about so you wait for a bunch
of lessons in your book
and there there really is a lot of great
advice in this book and I remember when
you were first writing the book and you
and I were discussing exactly what the
book was gonna be about because I asked
you about it and you'd suggested that it
might be sort of why you left the left
and I remember being slightly critical
of the title actually and you you
obviously took my advice I mean clearly
that was the deciding factor here and
you decided to move in a different
direction and one things I loved about
the book is that it really is a guide to
action and sort of in a mixture of your
story and also things that you've
learned along the way here one of the
things you talk about is the necessity
of embracing wake-up calls that you
experience in your life and and you
talked in your book about the situations
that led you to sort of these these
come-to-jesus moments for lack of a
better term the road to Damascus stuff I
remember that my mentor Andrew Breitbart
always used to consider the the Clarence
Thomas hearings is sort of wake-up call
because he was watching as the Democrats
defended Bill Clinton hitting on
anything that had two legs in some
things that didn't have two legs at the
same time they were ripping up Clarence
Thomas and he thought of himself they
thought this is crazy I mean that the
hypocrisy here is nuts you talk about
your wake-up calls what were your
wake-up calls that led you to move from
a guy who was doing stuff for the young
turks to being a guy who I think it's
fair to say is fairly critical of the
Young Turks well I mean I just don't
care about the Young Turks but so I lay
out three wake-up calls specifically
three moments that happened to me over
my over the last couple years that
really sort of sparked and then
Unleashed my political awakening but the
one that I've spoke the least about so I
think it would be the most interesting
to talk to you about is a guy that I'm
sure you know David Webb you must know
David Webb from from Fox in Sirius XM
right yeah so David Webb I was once on
The Young Turks and now remember I'm a
lefty I'm a progressive the whole
frickin thing I'm on The Young Turks
Network and they're playing a clip of
Fox News and David Webb was on Fox News
and it doesn't even matter what he was
talking about all of the hosts that I
was on the panel with started saying
that he's an Uncle Tom and he's a
sellout and he hates his own community
he's self-hating all of the things that
you hear about anyone who dare be a
black conservative right see we hear
this about our friend Larry elder we
hear this about Thomas soul Candis Owens
etc etc now I'm watching them go on and
on about what a self-hating black man he
is and what a sellout he is and what
they didn't know was that years before I
had joined the Young Turks I used to
have a show on Sirius
I'm a radio show and David was on the
right channel and I was a big lefty at
the time but we met in the hallway one
day and we quickly struck up a
friendship and I used to go on his show
every other week or so and we would
debate topics we we disagreed on
everything I mean he was firmly on the
right I'm giving him is my left hand I
was firmly on the left he was firmly on
the right and we would debate everything
and then afterwards we'd go out to
dinner and we'd have some whiskey and it
was all good and I know that David Webb
is a good man
I know he is an honest man who's
fighting for what he believes in and
then to see a bunch of supposed tolerant
Pro diversity lefties here a black man
say some things that they don't like and
then call him self-hating it became so
starkly obvious to me that this was
racism oh you guys see a black man who
doesn't behave the way you expect a
black man not expect the way you would
demand a black man behave and now he's
all of the worst things in the world
well what is prejudice it is prejudging
and you are prejudging him you think
black people must all think the same
thing that actually is his bigotry that
actually is racism and I think what
happened to me in that moment was it was
it did it wasn't ephemeral anymore it
was actually real and tangible because I
knew him so it wasn't just some
imaginary person on television so that
was one that really that really did it
to me the two others one of them I've
spoke quite a bit about and I know you
know quite well which was when Sam
Harris was on Real Time with Bill Maher
and Ben Affleck they were talking about
radical Islam and Sam was saying you
know we have to be able to criticize
ideas but you shouldn't be bigoted
towards people which is such a simple
but important idea you should be able to
criticize any idea you should be able to
criticize any religious idea you should
be able to criticize any political idea
any idea about if you don't like how the
NBA rules are you should be able to
criticize those rules too but you don't
want to be bigoted towards people and
that was all that Sam Harris who I
didn't even know who he was I was
watching it live and I didn't even know
who sam Harris was at the time but
obviously I I knew Bill Maher and
Affleck turns to the two of them and the
famous now-infamous lion is he calls
them gross and racist
and they were nothing of the sort and
then immediately I watched the feeding
frenzy over the next couple weeks of all
the usual suspects Daily Beast and Vox
in HuffPo and BuzzFeed suddenly saying
that Bill Maher is a racist and this
mild-mannered neuroscientist who said
nothing racist he was a racist and I
thought man
Bill Maher has stood up for everything
you guys purport to believe in for for
20 years he's been 20 years maybe 30
years he's been fighting the fight of
the left the good fight of the left
relentlessly of nailing Republicans and
conservatives rightly or wrongly now
because ben affleck batman says one
thing that sort of sounds right if you
don't think about it now he's evil and
that was another wake-up call to me
because i saw them doing that with
everyone anyone you disagree with is
suddenly evil and then very briefly the
last one and this was the final straw
for me i had already planned on leaving
but this was in January right around
middle of the month January of 2015 it
was when the Charlie Hebdo attacks a
bunch of jihadists broke into the
Charlie Hebdo cartoonists offices in
Paris France and immediately I was on a
panel on The Young Turks and there was
no there was almost no sympathy for the
victims the sympathy suddenly went to oh
you poked a bear you shouldn't make
cartoons of these things now meanwhile
they made fun of Orthodox Jews all the
time a Charlie Hebdo of course they made
fun of the Pope and Christianity and
every idea Under the Sun but suddenly if
you made fun of this set of ideas even
though Charlie Hebdo wasn't making fun
of Muslim people they were making fun of
jihadists which we need to do by the way
we need to mock the things that would
love to control us and destroy us but
the outrage had nothing to do with the
victims the outrage was that we might
then cause bigotry to other people and
it just seemed so insidious and
backwards highlighted by one of the
hosts pounding on the table and
screaming about how all ninety something
percent of the Charlie Hebdo covers were
against Muslims and it's something like
three out of 400 or something like that
there were far more against the Pope and
Orthodox Jews and the rest of it but
anyway all of these things they just
added up to where the rubber started
meeting the road that was really it
and then suddenly over the course of the
next year when I started doing my
long-form interview show once I left the
Young Turks I started talking to some
conservatives you included and Larry
elder and a bunch of others and suddenly
I was able to sit across from people who
I had some pretty stark disagreements
with but you didn't want to kill me for
it you didn't want to silence me for it
you didn't want to take my job for it
and then that really opened up a whole
other world that I didn't expect and one
of the things that they talked about
there and that I think really is the
crux of the ability to have a
conversation is not maligning your
opponents sort of perspective and not
the perspective maligning their motives
and and it seems like the easiest thing
to do twitter is the worse for this I
mean you talk in your book and you've
talked before about how one of the
things that I think makes and I think
it's one of things that makes you a
happier person and a good voice is is
that you really have disconnected and
some pretty significant ways from social
media social media rewards people from
aligning other people's motives it's not
just that you can wreck somebody's
argument or point out where they've been
wronged it's that if they did something
wrong it wasn't a pure mistake it's
because they must be stupid or there
must be evil and and social media
absolutely rewards that it's it's sort
of a microcosm of the darkest side of
humanity but so much of politics is
built around it so you've made the
decision that you are going to really
restrict your social media diet in a
pretty significant way you know I even
even I read I have a social media diet
once a week of Friday nights and
Saturday night I can't be on social
media that wasn't enough of a diet for
me I mean I remember that I started took
your advice and several months ago maybe
almost a year ago at this point actually
I started really really restricting and
cutting back on my use of Twitter now
I've fallen back into the old drug fix
in the middle of the the corona virus
pandemic because everybody is searching
for news all the time but it's not good
for the Soul it really is bad for us I
wonder if you want to talk a little bit
about your social media diet and how
you've restricted sort of what your
intake of this sort of stuff well I
remember when I first started doing this
weekend off thing and you tweeted at me
and you're like yeah Dave we've been
doing it for 5,000 years it's called a
Shabbat and it's like yeah well I took
Shabbat and I added an extra day because
I really try to take the weekends off
although I'm in the same situation as
you during this corona situation I have
been on there a bit more but one of the
things that I'm trying to do is I try
not to tweet about
politics on the weekends but I'll try to
tweet about food or music that I'm
listening to or my community of Reuben
report comm we do a week a weekend movie
together where we watch and then we do a
video chat after I'm trying to use it
for some other things other than the
constant destruction but I think to your
broader point about how we all behave on
there look we try I see it with you and
I know for myself it's like there are
moments when aoc says something so
stupid and so patently dishonest and so
so twisted that you want to destroy her
right and and anyone watching this knows
there's enough videos on YouTube ben
shapiro capital destroys college kid or
whatever not coming from ben shapiro or
the daily wire usually coming from
somebody else but the nature of how we
all do this internet game and how the
cliques work in the algorithm work it
sort of constantly rewards I don't even
want to say bad behavior because
sometimes people kind of do deserve to
get called out on their nonsense but it
rewards sort of this endless game of
one-upsmanship so for me I have found
that if I try not to look at it on the
on the weekends I find that helpful I
really really try not to and this is
this one I would really recommend for
anyone is don't bring your cell phone
your iPhone whatever you got don't bring
it into your bedroom like don't it
should not be the last thing you look at
at night and it shouldn't be the first
thing that you look at in the morning
just doing that will give you so that
when you get out of bed because
otherwise you do it you grab you go over
to your nightstand you grab your phone
you look at it and for people like us I
can do a quick scroll and have a hundred
people telling me to go F myself before
I even brush my teeth now that's not a
great way to start the day you probably
get 300 doing it and I might be a little
conservative in the numbers there so I
think doing some simple things like that
and then the other thing that I do is I
do this August off the grid which not
this past year but the year before you
welcomed me back on the grid after no
news no electronics no television no
nothing and guess what it turned out
that I didn't even miss that much you
know a lot of the stuff that you told me
about that I missed during my August off
the grid I did miss the John McCain had
passed away so that that's a big news
story that was one but a lot of the
stuff that you told me about was about
Michael Cohen think how actually
relevant that is if you think about
today's world right now and I think if
there's ever a time to step away from
some of that stuff I think August is the
right time to do it and your summer in a
clear minded way and if you can't do
that try try to one week things per year
Christmas - doesn't doesn't matter what
religion you are but we all shut down
basically from Christmas to New Year's
right so take that one week just don't
be on social media or the last week of
the summer right before Memorial Day you
know that last week of August into into
that Tuesday basically after Memorial
Day just to shut it down a little bit
because you just gotta remember been we
all even though we're creatures of this
thing we make our living zon this thing
we love this thing in so many ways none
of this existed 25 years ago we are we
are technological adolescents in this
thing and we don't know how it's
changing us and one of the things I am
concerned about even though as I said
before I'm hopeful because of Corona is
that right now we're only socializing
because of this stuff right this is our
only mode of outside communication
you've got your wife there and your kids
there but beyond that you know we can
zoom with family and friends but now
everything about our communication with
the outside world is now dictated by big
tech and you know there's a million
reasons related to censorship why that's
dangerous so I just think we have to be
careful with all these tools we don't
know exactly what they are we grab them
we love them and you know you may find
out that fire can be used for bad not
just to heat the food so in a second I
want to ask you about some of the
statements just made about social media
and the censorship and then because
you've started a company that is largely
directed at fighting against that sort
of censorship we'll get to that in just
one second first it's kind of rough to
shop for mom I mean right what does mom
actually want from you yeah I could do
the flowers I suppose but you know it's
a really meaningful gift how about
preserving your families and memories
legacy box
it's a fantastic service it's a super
simple mail and service to have all your
home movies and pictures digitally
preserved on the thumb drive DVD or the
cloud don't let those priceless family
memories disappear because that's what
tends to happen instead here's a great
idea Mother's Day is fast approaching
what are you getting mom how about
memories that aren't gonna get dusty or
fade away legacy box will help bring new
life to your old media by unlocking
those trapped family memories and
putting them in a modern digital format
that's easy to use we've been using the
legacy
I've done this for my parents we loaded
up a bunch of films film reels sent it
off to legacy box can't wait to get
those back legacy box is a way for you
to easily and affordably digitally
preserve your past the process from
start to finish is really easy a pax you
send your tapes their team digitizes
everything by hand and you get back
perfectly preserved digital copies on a
thumb drive DVD or doe cloud ready to
watch share and enjoy plus of course the
originals for a limited time legacy box
is running a 50% off Mother's Day
special which is a great deal order your
legacy box today take advantage of the
great offer it's one of the best
discounts they've ever offered
go to legacy box calm /ban save 50%
while supplies last
that's legacy box com /ban save 50% off
for mother's day legacy box calm / been
already so let's talk a little bit about
social media censorship so you've had
wide experience we have over the Daily
wire also obviously of situations in
which it feels like social media is
cracking down on you now it would be
ungrateful for me here at the Daily wire
to say that social media has been
terrible to us it hasn't I mean Facebook
we've been wildly successful and
obviously we have an incredibly
successful YouTube channel but you've
personally had lots of situations over a
room of Rubin report where they've
demonetized your videos preemptively I
remember they D monetize the
conversation that I think you Jordan and
I had that had 5 million views and they
D monetize that one if I'm not mistaken
and they kind of as a rule they
basically just D monetize you right off
the bat over a YouTube for no apparent
reason so what's what's your take on
what should happen with these companies
and I want you to talk a little about
locals calm because that's the company
that you've started to try and fight
some of this stuff without calling for
overt government regulation yeah so look
my general premise on this is I want
these companies to be able to operate
however they want to operate now that
does get a little messy because the
amount of power that Google and Facebook
and Twitter and YouTube now have over us
is unimaginable right the amount of
information that they control and the
way they control the highway of
information ten years ago we could have
never imagined how powerful that would
be that being said my preference is to
get the government out of the way and
you just let them do their thing now
people will always say when I get you
know ten videos in a row D monetized or
something and I'm complaining about it
on Twitter and I'm tagging Susan
Wojcicki who is the YouTube CEO who I
know you've had some conversations with
and I've had
conversations with of course they were
all off the record at least for mine so
I can't even repeat what was said but
but people will say Dave you how can you
be complaining how could you be
complaining you don't want the
government to be involved how can you
complain and it's like no no no that's
the complete reverse of how this all
works I don't want the government
involved so I'm using my voice to put
pressure on the company as a public
person to change their behavior that is
that is the opportunity you have in a
free society all that being said I
believe that we have no idea how they're
manipulating us whether it's through
algorithmic tricks or D boosting or
switching search things or shadow bands
on Twitter I mean one of the stories
that barely anyone picked up but as of
January 1st 2020 they Twitter actually
put shadow banning in their TOS in their
Terms of Service they are telling us
that they will throttle certain accounts
now they don't tell you who they're
doing it to or when they're doing it but
again as especially right now in the
midst of Corona when the only way we can
communicate with each other we can't get
together in real life right as you've
talked about one of the things you miss
right now is going to temple on Fridays
well ok you can't do that right now so
they've all of the way you can get to
the world is through their pipes so I'm
very worried of all the things they can
do to us and finally after screaming
about it for you know a couple years and
having all these conversations with all
of you guys I started locals not common
the idea was that what we need for
anyone that creates anything whether
you're a political guy like us whether
you're a gamer or an unboxer or you run
a child's baseball league or you're a
non-profit or a synagogue or a church or
literally anything anyone that wants to
digital president's presence you should
own your digital home and that's what
we're doing we're building digital homes
for creators so you can have video and a
news feed and you can like and you can
comment you own all the content you own
the data and and here's the thing we're
not creating a platform what we're
creating our digital homes that you can
choose to connect with other people's
digital homes for a network effect so if
someone comes into to Rubin report calm
and they're just a relentless
trol or they're just you know just there
to raise chaos I can boot them out now
that's not that I don't respect free
speech but I don't welcome everyone in
my home to say whatever they want to me
you could say whatever you want on the
public street out outside but the beauty
is we're not deep if I kick someone out
of my local I'm not deep platforming
them because they can still be in anyone
else as local as long as they abide by
their rules you set your own rules in
your local so originally the idea behind
this was that we're creating digital sea
stance you know Peter Thiel was big on
the idea of these sea Stead's
floating in in the water where we could
do experimental medical treatments and
all sorts of things I'm creating digital
homes for creators we we managed to
raise a nice amount of money in the
midst of coronavirus which was probably
the worst time since 9/11 to raise some
money but we did well and we're building
and and we'll see what happens you know
can David beat Goliath in this case can
Dave beat Google I don't know we'll see
but you know I I just thought I had to
put into practice the things that I'm
always talking about and that's that's
what brought me to it I want to get back
to some of the lessons that you have in
don't burn this book one of the ones
that really struck me because it was
actually rather moving is your
discussion of your relationship with
Jordan Peterson so obviously Jordan is
on the cover of the book you're very
tight with Jordan I'm friends with
Jordan but you are really good friends
with Jordan I mean you you were you were
on the road with Jordan for for two
years as his warm-up act essentially and
the events are fantastic if you've ever
been to one of the events with Jordan
and Dave I'd highly recommend it
I was privileged to to help warm up the
crowd and one of the events in it really
was a lot of fun that might have been
the best night of the whole tour because
that was right at the end and we we did
it hear it in LA at the Orpheum and you
know when you do something in LA all the
agents are there and there's just like a
different feel to it the crowd was
electric
you were the surprise guest you brought
me a little cake because people are the
lefties are very upset that you won't
cook bake me a gay wedding cake although
I have no reason to believe you're a
decent Baker I don't want your cake but
you brought me a cake people were very
exciting and it was a perfect example of
the hypocrisy of the progressives
because we do this event in front of
3,000 people the crowd goes freaking
bananas were up there we're making jokes
at each other mocking each other you do
a pretty funny impression of Jordan I
mean everyone he was a freaking love
fest in that room
people started posting the videos of it
online and suddenly the amount of hate
that I got Dave Reubens self hating gay
stands on stage with homophobe Ben
Shapiro and white supremacist Jordan
Peterson and it's like man it we took a
room of truly diverse people and gave
them a great time we put differences
aside that's what America is all about
that that's a beautiful thing that we
need to cherish and here are the
supposed tolerant people who are upset
that we actually were able to accomplish
that and now the fact that that we you
and I can be nice to each other really
does drive people it's pretty larrya to
talk about about Jordan for a second so
you see Jordans been you know going
through some very very difficult times I
don't you don't have to be a
spokesperson here I have you heard from
him how he's doing so I I don't want to
say anything that's not publicly known
at the moment I did see him a few months
ago I can tell you this he's getting
better he will be back you know watching
some of the vitriol when it was
announced that he had got hooked on
these benzos which by the way you know
there is a little bit of
miscommunication or misinformation about
what happened there he was very open and
would talk about it often during the
lectures that he was taking a small
amount of this we found out in the
middle of the tour that his wife had
what they thought was terminal cancer
thank God it turned out not to be
terminal and she's actually doing much
better
but he you know try to imagine this guy
who was a mild-mannered psychologist and
professor who suddenly became the
world's father in a way you know like
the really the preeminent public thinker
of our time traveling the world the fame
the hit pieces you know you remember the
enforcement noggin II hit piece in the
New York Times and you remember the
Kathy Newman so what you're saying his
moment and all those things living
through all of that then thinking his
wife is gonna die I mean I was literally
at lunch with him we were at lunch at a
steak house of course when he got the
call about his wife I saw this man lived
through something unbelievably
extraordinarily horrible or or as he
would say brutal and always put his best
foot forward so I can't say anything
more about that specifically other than
I never saw him break one of those rules
and and I saw him just trying to be true
and if he gave me anything through
osmosis or accident it's that I am
really really trying to do that and it
doesn't mean that I do at every moment
of every day but I try to incorporate
those ideas those rules and just being
with someone that you know his whole
life his whole mission really was you
know if you fix yourself if you clean
your room if you stand up straight with
your shoulders back you might start
fixing the world and I saw him trying to
do that and I saw him actually
accomplishing it so you know he's got a
little he's got something to deal with
right now and I have no doubt that he
will deal with it and that he'll be back
yeah you tell a pretty great story in
the book about how Jordan dresses when
when he's out in public and it is true I
mean Jordan dresses the same way all the
time he's old enough to remember when
Jordan dressed more like a swamp like I
remember a big in England when Jordan
was not nearly as natty and his attire
as as he is now and as you point out in
the book he he sort of took it on
himself that he was going to dress in a
particular way and then that is how
Jordan dresses all the time
and and I was wondering he talked a
little bit about some of the lessons
that you've learned from Jordan
yeah well the dressing is it's just a
very simple one but it's it's just to
present yourself a certain way to the
world and I asked him during the Q&A so
when we did the shows for for your
audience that didn't see any of the
shows I would do about 15 minutes a
warm-up up top and just get everybody
laughing and having a good time then
Jordan would give about an hour and a
half lecture and then we do about a 45
minute Q&A together at the end and one
of the questions that would often come
up is Jordan when did you become a
middle-aged male fashion icon and he
would say well you know when we started
this tour and I had this book I thought
I'm gonna give it everything I got and
part of that is is looking the part that
I want to look so he went from those
frumpy yellow shirts that you've seen on
YouTube from those old lectures into
three-piece fitted sharp you know suits
and Italian shoes and the whole thing
and there was one day where we were in
Stockholm Sweden and you know it's so
funny because Sweden is one of the
places that the Socialists and Bernie
Sanders they always point to Sweden as
if it's their shangri-la this absurdly
tiny mostly homogeneous country which is
less homogeneous now and having all
sorts of problems but they don't like to
tell you that but they always say we
could just model ourselves after Sweden
we'd be in much better shape well the
two shows that we did in sweet
sold out literally in three minutes
three minutes for two shows and the
foreign minister of Sweden issued a
statement when we came back to Sweden we
did one and then I think we left for
Finland we come back the Foreign
Minister issues a statement that she
wishes that Jordan Peterson would crawl
back from the rock that he came from and
we get there and it's like people in
Sweden have a serious they have a
crippling free speech issue there
because the society is so conforming
that people are just afraid to say what
they think about about anything about
immigration about economics but the
whole slew of things but the story
quickly we're in Stockholm and it was
extremely windy that day and I just
wanted a hat to walk around the city so
I walk into H&M which is one of their
proud exports I walk into H&M and
there's a guy grab the hat there's a
young kid he's probably about 20 years
old in front of me online and he says to
the cashier in English he says this is
the first suit I've ever bought I'm
going to see dr. Jordan Peterson tonight
and the cashier who's about the same age
looks at him and says I'm going to see
Petersen tonight and I tapped the kid on
the shoulder and I said hi and they
immediately knew who I was and I thought
this is absolutely incredible
I am I am across the world right now
right I'm across the world and here are
two young people one of whom who's
buying the first suit of his life so
that he can present himself in a
responsible way to go to an event to
hear how he can further fix his life how
much more do you want to that and then
one other I'll give you real quick we're
in and I think it was in Dublin and you
know when you do these theater shows as
the performer you don't walk out the
front because you know you'll get mobbed
or whatever so they have a little
theater door on the side we walk out
after hours and this is a long day of
travel and you know he's signing
autographs he's shaking hands the whole
thing we're beat at the end of the day
we're in the alley and we see these two
guys hugging one looks like he's about
60 the other ones maybe in his mid-20s
they come up to us they both have tears
in their eyes and it turned out that
they were a father and son who hadn't
seen each other in five or six years who
by chance both were at the event because
they had bought the book and started to
fix their lives and then they
reconnected that that night it's like
how much more of a real world example of
goodness do you want
you know and I could give you a million
of those stories so in a second I want
to ask you about the the sort of hatred
that you've received obviously we've all
everybody IDW as far as I'm aware is but
maybe that's the Uniting factors that
all of us have been the recipient of
outside hatred for the stuff that we
have said or in many cases not said get
to that in just a second first it is
really uplifting as an American to see
how many great companies there are right
now doing everything they can to help us
get through this unbelievably trying
time and our sponsors over at zip
recruiter they understand that we can't
be overwhelms we have to keep our loved
ones safe and protect our communities
and we have to work to stay strong to
stay connected we also have to work
toward a better economy we have to work
toward an economy that continues to work
for all of that to happen we have to
work together at zip recruiter they
continue to connect employers and people
every single day today is different than
their norm they're partnering with first
responders innovators government
officials the medical community
manufacturers transportation and food
distribution and delivery to make sure
that we are finding the right people for
the right jobs right now and that is
deeply important with so many people out
of work and so many employers looking
for great employees to help get their
businesses back on the right footing zip
recruiter is helping make this happen
check out zip recruiters calm right now
zip recruiter dot-com slash will work
together that zip recruit calm slash
work together again they're helping to
connect all sorts of people with great
employers right now making sure that
everybody is in the right job super
important stuff in a time when you know
things are pretty difficult zip recruits
doing amazing work of zip recruit comm
slash work together so one of the
chapters of the book Dave is about stop
worrying about whether you're not see
now this is something that you've taken
it particularly on the chin floor
because you have had the temerity to
have on Rubin report a bunch of people
who people very often think of as pretty
terrible and you've received an
inordinate amount of rage about this the
suggestion being that if you bring them
on the show and you ask them questions
but the questions aren't as directed and
harsh as people would like them to be
this is somehow you platforming them so
how do you deal with the easier
accusation I think is always the they
call you a Nazi right which is up which
is absurd you're very Jewish gay man who
is a classical liberal like I can't
think of many people other than myself
who I would think of as
Nazis you know Jordan is been called a
Nazi I've been called a Nazi Sam has
been called a Nazi like everybody is
called a Nazi and frankly none of us we
did not see that coming but when it
comes to you know the accusation that
you know you and on your show that you
need to be harsher with some of the
guests that you've had on how do you
deal with those sorts of accusations
well you know it's kind of funny to me
because I think one of the things that
made my show special is that in a time
when everything was getting smaller
right Twitter and vine videos at the
time six seconds and Instagram the rest
everything was getting smaller and I
said I'm gonna do a long-form interview
show and I'm actually thrilled that you
know Rogan was starting right around the
same time or that you do this show I I
think I mailed you or I texted you like
the weaker show came out and I was like
it's great you're doing an interview
show I first off as a general rule I
don't even think we're not in
competition but I believe in competition
it's like if you suddenly were like just
every interviewer doing made my
interviews feel thin and pale and
whatever I would bust my butt even more
I mean that's that's I always operate
that way
myself and I know that you would do the
same what I started doing was let me
have respectful conversation everything
on cable news is people destroying each
other sound bites there's no way you can
extrapolate an idea properly there's no
way you can understand truly what
someone's thinking when you have five
heads in a box all screaming over each
other and that's all we were getting
especially out of cable news I thought
let me sit down with people let me kind
of tell them what I'm thinking here what
they're thinking and see what happens
what what happened and I think the
reason that I get so much hate was my
first show is in September of 2015 and
it was as an interview show of the
Reuben report and my first guest was Sam
Harrison my whole goal was to clean up
the mess that we discussed previously
and I wanted to do it in a way where we
could take like the eight things that he
had been most maligned about and just
put them into little five-minute videos
so that if he ever got attacked he could
just say well here's the answer here's
the real answer that's not really what I
said and here's the real answer I did
that and what I realized was after the
two-hour conversation I walked I was a
Torah TV which is Larry King's digital
network at the time it was our first
show there I wasn't planning on doing an
interview show I was going to still do a
sort of panel view style show that I
doing with the young turks but the
second I was done I was like that felt
real that felt important and valuable to
me and I thought that's what I want to
do so we immediately flipped the format
that's what we decided to do and what's
interesting is from that conversation it
opened up doors to many people that were
thinking the same things I was you know
people that were liberal in in the
truest sense of it and you know another
one a great example is Maajid Nawaz who
is a true liberal he is a classical
liberal who is hated by the left and now
sort of embraced by the right and there
were just tons and tons of people that
that experience kept happening but my
feeling was whether I agreed with you or
not so like the first time that I had
you on the show which now feels like
several lifetimes ago when we were back
at aura TV we had never met before you
were just to me you were Ben Shapiro
from Twitter some guy from Twitter who
you know he's a conservative he talks
fast I don't know we'll see what
happened we sat down it was very obvious
we had some disagreements but the idea
that I wouldn't have treated you
respectfully short of you not treating
me respectfully it's not what I grew up
with and this I think was one of the
things that I really learned from
writing the book is that you know
there's an old joke if you have four
Jews at a table you have five opinions
because Jews for for the history of
history whether you come from
you know rabbis debating you know the
the the Talmud to just the more Seinfeld
ization of Judaism culturally where it's
just people talking everything out
that's kind of what Jews have it's like
that you know there isn't a Pope there
isn't like the guy who tells everybody
what to do what they're supposed to
think kind of thing there's more of
we're all sort of thinking different
things some of us may be Orthodox some
of us may be conservative some of us may
be reformed some of us may be a theist
but still culturally Jewish whatever and
I and I know you have different feelings
on all of those things but the the
combined feeling of all that is that
debate was always healthy so at my
family at all the holidays whether it
was Passover you know a religious
holiday or whether it was Thanksgiving a
secular holiday we would argue
everything anything you could think of
would be argued about all all night long
at the dinner table and then dessert
would be served and everybody was okay
so I grew up with that that
that you can argue things out you know
I'm also from New York you can argue
things out and you don't punch each
other you know I am I I grew up in Long
Island I was born in Brooklyn but most
of my formative adult years were in
Manhattan and it's like in Manhattan you
have all sorts of people doing all sorts
of things and you can't run around
punchin everybody and calling everybody
a racist and a bigot so so to directly
answer your question though every single
interview that I've ever done
truly I have I have never treated any of
my guests any differently I have never
tried to get anyone or undercut anyone I
have genuinely been there to hear what
they think I think that I've usually I'm
sure not always but usually asked the
right questions is it possible that now
and again a follow-up that I should have
got to I missed well you're doing an
interview show right now it's you know
it's very possible sometimes someone's
very long-winded and you want to get
back to something but next thing you
know it's six it's six minutes later and
then you just have to move on to
something else so that's how I conduct
my interviews I would say a good example
of this in a way is when I had Marianne
Williamson on remember that hot month
when she was going to be the Democratic
nominee I had her on and she's a
collectivist she believes that white
people are guilty for what they've done
to black people this is a ridiculous
concept to me because I'm not guilty for
my father's sins now no one in my family
owned slaves anyway but I'm not guilty
for anyone else's sins other than my own
so collectivism as a rule is is an
absurd ideology to me but I didn't want
to treat her ideas I didn't want to
battle her the entire time I wanted to
hear what she said the one thing that I
did which I think was appropriate was
about halfway through I said Marianne I
just want to say one thing the lens
through which you view the world is a
collectivist lens and the lens which I
view the world is an individualist lens
that's a fundamental impasse that I just
have to put out there so that we can now
have a normal conversation because
otherwise I'm bringing people in here to
browbeat them constantly and I'm just
not that interested in that but I don't
mind I don't mind criticism I actually
like criticism when when it's healthy
criticism I like it actually that's how
you get better
so you mentioned in there so religions I
may as well ask you you make some sort
of religious overtures in in the
that are interesting so where are you
when we first met that by the time we
were done I would have you observing
Sabbath like full-on is it not just a
media braclet full-on observing Sabbath
so where are we in your journey and how
am i doing then I'm gonna have you
baking gay cake so you know we'll see
what happens here look what what I what
I would say is this and and I and I do
write about this in the book that it is
it has become fairly obvious to me over
the last couple years to you know
speaking to many of the people who
you've talked to from Sam Harris and
Steven Pinker and Michael Shermer and
Jordan Peterson and the rest that there
has to be empirical truths outside of us
that set order in the universe one of
the reasons we're seeing such chaos out
of the left is that secularism run
rampant it gives you what the left is it
gives you people with a completely
competing set of ideas often that have
nothing to do with reality just based on
how they feel at any moment and the
reason they're constantly destroying
each other is because well okay I feel
$15 minimum wages right so I'm morally
good then the next person comes and says
the $20 thing and then they're morally
good now you got to cut them down and
there's a million versions of this we
could go through the founders of the
United States talked about god-given
rights the United States does not make
me free I was born free you are born
free as a human being whether you want
to call it a god-given right or it's
your it's your birthright as a human
being the the government can protect
your rights it should protect your
rights and it can take those rights away
but it doesn't it did not make me free
and the only the real reason that I came
around to this which I know is very much
in line with with what you believe and
it's very much certainly in live with
what Jordan believes is that it's the
only thing that over generations has
allowed us to set some sort of order to
the bad ideas of the day so when there's
a certain set of crew the Liberals of
today let's say who all believe it all
happened at the Enlightenment and it's
like yeah a lot of great ideas happen
from the Enlightenment right free
thought and open inquiry and a lot of
the stuff that I talk about all the time
about the individual although you in
your last book you talk about how the
roots of that also came from Greek
culture and from from Jerusalem but the
point is that
there isn't it took churning of ideas
for thousands of years to get to the
Enlightenment so to say it all started
there it strikes me as very thin and
when we live in a time right now where
post-modernism is so hot and the idea is
that the the time-tested bad ideas of
the past of socialism and communism
somehow we're becoming cool again it
seems to me that the secular world has
no way of countering it that's why
liberalism has been decimated by the
progressives the progressives came in
with a battering ram and liberals are
usually nice and liberal say oh we're
just we're tolerant and yes you can do
whatever you want there's 80,000 genders
and I'm an oppressor because I'm white
in a series of crazy things they have no
mechanism to stop it you know what the
mechanism to stop it is it's what it's
actually what you guys have been
preaching for a long time and it took me
a long time to get there which is that
there are empirical truths outside of us
there are good there is good and bad and
it's not because of us it's because it
exists and the best way and this is
really where I lay it in the book the
best way to explain that that humans
have to me seems to be the biblical
stories there is a reason that I believe
that Dave can beat Google and it's
because David beat Goliath there is
those stories have some meaning over
time that will allow us to flourish as
human beings and does that mean that you
can be completely secular and atheist
and and totally moral of course you can
but I don't think a society can function
on that over the over the long haul so
Dave one of the other areas where I'm
determined to move you is on the
abortion issue you don't have debated
this 35 times on on your show and you've
asked yourself reluctantly pro-choice my
goal is to make you more and more
reluctant until the point where you are
no longer pro-choice so how am i doing
on that score right now all right first
off wait I didn't fully give you what
you wanted on the other one David and I
have been doing Shabbat pretty
consistently the Lambs which I think you
know I probably do it for more of a
secular lens than you do it but I mean
you know we'll have some wine will have
some challah if we can get it it's often
sold out here in Los Angeles there's a
lot of Jews here but but then also going
on the idea
that it is the end of the week it's the
time to shut down as we discussed
earlier whatever so that's like a
secular lens on something that is
timeless which is consistent with
everything else that I'm telling you
here as for abortion I mention our
conversations in the in the chapter on
abortion when the last time you and I
sat here about abortion I was taking the
20 weeks thing and you said to me well
Dave if you're taking 20 weeks and my
argument was well that's when they they
know that the fetus can feel pain your
argument was well Dave if you're saying
they can feel pain at 20 you do
acknowledge it to life at 19 and I said
yes Ben actually as a thinking person I
have to concede that I'm not debating
it's not about life but my but my
position would be that if you care about
individual rights what you have to first
care about is the woman who is here and
now now to move my position to where I'm
at in the book I believe 12 weeks which
is the first trimester that that's the
cutoff I will again I want to say I do
believe that basically the point of
conception is life now we can talk about
the blastocyst that at four days and I
happen to know a lot about this right
now because as you know David and I just
deposited sperm and we're in the process
of having kids of our own so I'm well
aware of all the stuff that goes with
IVF and when they talk about selective
terminations and all sorts of things
right without getting too into the weeds
on all of that now what I believe is and
I think this is this might be the place
where the classical liberal lens and the
conservative lens are just slightly
different which is that I want as much
power to be given to that woman to make
the right choice as horrific as choice
as it might be and I think a twelve-week
position is more than enough time the
only thing I would say beyond that is
that if there are you know really
extenuating circumstances if the child
is going to be unable to function or
live any sort of fully actualized life I
think you can have some exceptions to
that and the dirty secret for the
conservatives here of course is that we
do know that a lot of conservatives who
say they are absolutely pro-life from
the moment of conception they know that
there are circumstances whether it's you
know that they find out about a genetic
test or health of the wife or a rape or
a series of other things where they
would do what they felt they had to do
but they publicly have another position
I mean I think most people know that
it's sort of the
we don't really talk about but I don't
really take any pleasure in this chat in
this topic but I but I would say this
I've moved in a certain way and as I
always tell you on Twitter I find
although I think your arguments and the
arguments of other pro-life people like
why the rows are quite compelling
I find it's the hysteria of the left
that has actually moved me more on this
because when they are for 8-month
abortions and quite literally something
called post birth abortions where you
can get to discuss with your doctor what
you want to do with the baby that is
that is a position that is impossible to
hold and they make they make what I
would say is any reasonable pro-choice
position even if you don't think it's
reasonable they make it very difficult
to hold but the last line of the chapter
in effect is saying now that you all
hate me let's move on so Dave what's
your media diet like these days now
obviously the media has fragmented in
new ways people see this is the end of
the world I obviously think that it's
quite a good thing because it used to be
that we were all controlled by a certain
number of key figures who would tell us
what we needed to know and by the way
you've seen a lot of this with regard to
coronavirus which is kind of shocking to
me actually is if you say okay listen
I'm perfectly willing to listen to the
experts and then the experts are like
well you know there's a lot of
uncertainty in these models hey well
there's a lot of uncertainty in those
mouths like ah you want to get people
out there back to work and you want
everyone infecting each other saying oh
hold up a second I just said exactly the
same thing that vouching and Burkes are
saying and when they say it it's them
being the experts when I just repeat
back to them what they said then it's me
taking coronavirus lightly the
narratives get set by the media and then
if you violate the narrative in any way
it's I mean it's amazing I spent the
last month saying to one side know guys
we should probably take this pretty
seriously and to the other side no we
should also take the economy pretty
seriously because there are some
difficult decisions that have to be made
here and just getting destroyed by
everyone over it so never have I had
less faith in the media to bring us any
element of truth on this sort of stuff
but where do you come down on on you
know you have a whole chapter in here
about how to spot fake news what is your
media diet consists of these days I mean
I assume you still read the New York
Times even those label both of us
gateways to the into the Nazi Party yes
yes it's a seminal moment in my life
when my dad went to get a bagel and
coffee at the same place he does every
Sunday for the last 40 years and someone
had
bring the New York Times up to him and
say oh I didn't know David was the
leader of the alright was a really
wonderful moment well I'll tell you this
just in the last couple days the New
York Times did a story on misinformation
in the age of coronavirus and they
talked about a tweet that went viral and
a bunch of a bunch of people we know
steven crowder and britt hume and a few
other people tweeted this article the
article was eventually taken down by
medium not by the author who is
analyzing data it was taken down by
medium and they talked about how this is
this is misinformation because he was he
wasn't being alarmist about coronavirus
I happen to know the author it's a guy
by the name of Aaron Jin I think he's a
decent fella i retweeted the article
because I thought you know in a time
when it's almost impossible to know
who's telling the truth I think it's
important that we all hear different
perspectives on things so they include
me in this chart showing that when I
tweeted it it really started going viral
and it's all about misinformation so I
screenshot it and I put it up and then I
didn't even tag the author from the New
York Times because I don't even bother
tagging these people anymore because as
you know they're not journalists they're
quote-unquote journalists I didn't even
tag the guy but he wrote back and said
something like we didn't quote mention
you you were just in a graph but I'm
glad you think you're flattered and I
thought you know it's it's it's this
exact type of glib doublespeak that is
exactly this is what I said to him on
Twitter I mean that you guys are
destroying your own profession you're
telling me when you put my name in a
chart in an article about misinformation
that's not mentioning me it's not
mentioning me and of course if you
google the definition of the word
mention it qualifies as I mentioned but
but what's happening right now is all
I've all I ask I tweet this all the time
all the media has to do you want to shut
up Ben Shapiro you want to stop scary
Dave Rubin you know what you do you
start behaving honestly but they can't
do it they have the ship has sailed the
thing that is the New York Times is just
the shell of the New York Times with a
bunch of progressive activists
underneath it I know someone that you
know too that works at the New York
Times who although I don't think this
person's talking to me anymore would
often tell me about how horrific Lee
woke
the entire newsroom had become and that
there's nothing even remotely close to
true coming out of that place they don't
even have a knob uh-uh
I'm buds Minh Ombudsman is that the word
yep yeah they don't even yeah they don't
have an ombudsman anymore which is the
person who's supposed to be
fact-checking the fact checker is in
effect you know a public editor they
don't even have that anymore it is
propaganda CNN is propaganda I'll give
you I'll give you a real good example of
this in December I'd missed you by a day
but we both spoke at the turning-point
student action summit event in West Palm
Beach and the day that I spoke I spoke
that morning Trump spoke that afternoon
and I had never heard Trump speak in
real time before in real life and we're
watching the speech and I was actually
in the second row and he you know it's
Trump he goes up there he's half
stand-up comic he's you know yeah you
know he's getting the crowd going the
whole thing and then he says this thing
about and he gives an hour and a half
speech and it's half prompter half
off-the-cuff and he says this thing
about wind power and he goes you know I
love wind power nobody knows more about
wind power than me I've studied wind
power my whole life and then he goes on
and on about wind power back to the
script but that line obviously those few
lines were obviously improved and I
turned to David and I said I bet you
that within an hour there's gonna be an
article about how Trump says he knows
more about wind power than anybody and
he studied it his whole life and then
voila all the articles come out Donald
Trump says he knows more about wind
power than anyone and it's like man you
idiots he was joking and then actually
made some interesting points about the
validity of wind power and how important
it should be or should not be and then
linked that also to failed other green
projects that we've done like Solyndra
and a whole bunch other stuff
anyway so where do I get my die from
it's very difficult I think you guys at
the Daily wire are doing a nice job I
think the blaze is doing a nice job I do
occasionally read some things out of The
Times in the Washington Post but they're
pretty crappy I try to pay attention you
know what I basically try to do is I on
Twitter I follow a multitude of people
from different perspectives and I try to
just riddle that into something that's
true but I think one of the saving
graces for me which is why I don't envy
the guys that have to do the grind every
day the hours and hours of content every
day is that it's really hard it's hard
- it's hard to distill truth out of this
madness all the time and I think you do
a pretty damn good job of it but it is
not easy to do and we what I want to do
is maybe take that information and then
make it accessible for the people that
that don't have the time to be paying
attention to this all day so Dave I want
to ask you a couple more questions I
want to ask you what you got coming up
for Rueben report the rest of the year I
also want to ask I heard that you have a
great meeting president from story that
I definitely want to hear but if you
actually wanna hear Dave's answer to
those questions you're gonna have to go
over to Daley we're calm and become a
subscriber there's lots of great stuff
happening for subscribers become a
subscriber right now and you hear the
end of our conversation over there at
Daley wire comm well Dave it's great to
talk to you congratulations on the book
people are going to enjoy it go check
out don't burn this book by Dave Rubin
and stay safe out there or in there
wherever we're out at this point really
appreciate it in sake dude thank you
Pierrot good seeing you
[Music]
the Ben Shapiro shows Sunday special is
directed by Mike joiner and produced by
Mathis Glover executive producer Jeremy
boring associate producer Katie Swinton
our guests are booked by Kaitlyn Manor
post-production is supervised by Alex's
and Gaara editing is by Jim Nichol audio
is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and makeup
is by Anika Geneva title graphics are by
Cynthia Angulo Avenger Pierrot shows
Sunday special is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20
[Music]